[Música]
ya son más de 60 los muertos por las
fuertes lluvias e inundaciones que
golpean el occidente de alemania y el
oriente de bélgica más de 2500
rescatistas han sido desplegados para
responder a la emergencia que fue
calificada de catástrofe por la
canciller alemana angela merkel
el primer ministro designado del líbano
saad hariri presentó su renuncia tras
nueve meses en el cargo en los que no
logró conformar un gobierno y aumenta la
presión en un país sumido en la crisis
económica hariri aseguró que su decisión
se debe a diferencias con el presidente
michel a uno
el pentágono confirmó que entrenó en el
pasado algunos de los colombianos que
han sido implicados por las autoridades
en haití en el asesinato del presidente
yo en el bois por su parte el jefe de la
policía colombiana dijo que los ex
militares sólo planeaban secuestrar al
mandatario para
y entregarlo a la agencia antidrogas de
eeuu
bienvenidos a esta emisión de noticias
en france 24 soy valentina torres
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos este informativo en alemania
donde ascendieron a 58 de las víctimas
tras las fuertes lluvias e inundaciones
que golpean el occidente del país y la
cifra podría aumentar porque las
autoridades estiman que decenas de
personas se encuentran desaparecidas con
medios locales belgas informan además de
9 fallecidos como consecuencia del mismo
fenómeno que ha dejado inmuebles y
vehículos arrasados roxana baspineiro
tiene los detalles
lluvias récord nunca antes vistas así se
vieron afectados los residentes de
ciudades como colonia coblenza y renania
palatinado algunas de las más afectadas
por las lluvias e inundaciones en el
oeste de alemania- un hecho que ha
causado la peor pérdida de vidas en el
país en años dejando decenas de muertos
y desaparecidos algunos edificios
derribados cierre de carreteras y cortes
de luz desde eeuu la cancillera angela
merkel que se encuentra en su último
viaje oficial a esta nación está
conmocionada por lo que describió como
una catástrofe sin dimensión son días
terribles para los habitantes de las
zonas inundadas mis pensamientos están
con ustedes y pueden confiar en que
todas las fuerzas de nuestro gobierno
federal regional y comunitario harán
colectivamente todo lo posible en las
condiciones más difíciles para salvar
vidas y mitigar los peligros y aliviar
la angustia que suben ante el fenómeno
sin precedentes los científicos
coinciden en que el cambio climático
provocado por el hombre es la principal
razón
según los expertos de meteorología al
menos 158 litros de lluvia por metro
cuadrado cayeron en sólo 24 horas las
más intensas desde que se llevan
registros en la región
las autoridades han declarado la
emergencia en las zonas afectadas
mientras continúan las labores de
rescate
en jets esta teoría el islanders a favor
del y ahora por supuesto también se
necesita ayuda del estado la cantidad de
ayuda aún no se puede cuantificar
financieramente porque no sabemos el
daño exacto ni alain el racing no
dejaremos solos a los municipios y a los
afectados brindaremos ayuda como estado
para que en área del norte westfalia se
mantenga unida en solidaridad en esta
situación según el servicio
meteorológico alemán se espera que las
lluvias intensas continúen hasta el
viernes
en otras noticias el primer ministro
designado de líbano saad hariri anunció
su dimisión luego de no haber podido
formar un gobierno y tras desacuerdos
con el presidente michel aún la atención
no cesa en un país con una profunda
crisis económica social y política y
tachado de corrupto por la comunidad
internacional el informe es de natalia
plazas
líbano no encuentra salida a su
estancamiento político tras nueve meses
de intentar formar un gobierno el primer
ministro designado del país
saad hariri anunció su renuncia lo hace
después de que el presidente michel aún
rechazara su propuesta de un ejecutivo
formado con 24 especialistas y está
claro que no podremos llegar a un
acuerdo con el presidente en nuestra
reunión le sugerí que se tomara más
tiempo para pensarlo si lo necesitaba
entonces dijo que no podíamos llegar a
un acuerdo por lo tanto me disculpo por
no poder formar un gobierno que dios
ayude al país
hariri fue designado en octubre con la
misión de formar un ejecutivo que
hiciera frente a la crisis económica
social política y sanitaria del país una
situación agudizada tras la mortal
explosión en el puerto de beirut que en
agosto mató a más de 200 personas y
forzó la renuncia del gobierno anterior
la negativa al gabinete será después de
meses de fallidas negociaciones y
bloqueos por la repartición de los
distintos ministerios entre hariri el
político sunita más influyente del
líbano y aún
aliado del grupo chiíta hezbollah la
renuncia del líder sunita podría dejar
al país en el limbo hasta las elecciones
de 2022 y agudizar así su crisis
múltiple con una devaluación de su
moneda local del 90 por ciento el banco
mundial ha descrito la depresión
económica que vive la nación como una de
las más graves de la historia moderna
esta queda entre la espada y la pared ya
que la comunidad internacional ha dicho
que no inyectará dinero al país hasta
que éste tenga un ejecutivo que impulse
profundas reformas anticorrupción
y avanza la investigación tras el
asesinato del presidente de haití yo en
el movice un portavoz del pentágono
confirmó que algunos de los ex militares
colombianos presuntamente relacionados
con el crimen recibieron entrenamiento
del departamento de defensa de eeuu en
el pasado por su parte del director de
la policía de colombia el general jorge
vargas informó que según las pesquisas
los colombianos supuestamente implicados
planeaban detener al jefe de estado y
entregarlo a la agencia antidrogas de
eeuu y la información que está manejando
la comisión con las autoridades
haitianas
es que inicialmente se abría y esto es
lo suministrado por los colombianos
d
entre comillas planear el arresto del
presidente
y ponerlo a disposición y esto es lo que
dicen ellos ese supuesto arresto de la
dea una investigación de la organización
mundial de la salud indica que la
pandemia está frenando la vacunación
infantil poniendo en riesgo a unos 23
millones de niños en todo el mundo de
contraer sarampión difteria tétano
aurora ba2 cuenta más
la oms se atribuyen nuevos daños
colaterales a la pandemia de kobe 19
la pandemia de kobe 19 provocó un gran
retroceso en la vacunación infantil que
nos hace retroceder más de una década se
estima que 23 millones de niños no han
recibido la vacuna básica a través de
los servicios de inmunización de rutina
en 2020 estas cifras representan el
mayor número de niños sin protección
desde 2009 la investigación de la uem se
estima un alza en el porcentaje de
menores desprotegidos de enfermedades
como la difteria el tétano y la tos
ferina sería un 17% de niños sin
protección a nivel mundial
gris estos últimos datos muestran un
aumento alarmante del número de niños
que no recibieron ninguna vacuna a los
que llamamos niños de dosis cero
poniendo en juego la vida de millones de
jóvenes el principal factor que explica
este descenso es la pandemia que hizo
que muchas familias no llevaran a sus
hijos a vacunarse por los confinamientos
o por temor a contagiarse de kobe 10
y el país donde más menores quedaron
desprotegidos en términos absolutos fue
india con 3.5 millones de niños que no
recibieron la vacuna contra la difteria
el tétano y la tos ferina
juani a medida que pasamos de 2020 donde
vimos un período de compromiso social
para reducir la transmisión de estas
enfermedades prevenibles por vacunación
a 2021 se acerca potencialmente una
verdadera crisis para la protección de
la niñez y no queremos llegar a esa
crisis
la uem se subraya que sin medidas
concertadas el mundo afrontará mayores
riesgos de brotes de enfermedades
infecciosas evitables con vacunas como
el sarampión la tos ferina
y finalizamos en francia con noticias
del festival de cine de cannes que
empieza a llegar a su fin colombia
participa indirectamente en el evento
con la película memoria que fue
estrenada este jueves nuestra enviada
social erika olabarría nos dio más
detalles la bandera de colombia de filo
esta noche por la alfombra roja del
festival de cannes y es que finalmente
pudimos ver en competencia oficial
memoria la película del tailandés
apichatpong weerasethakul una película
de un director asiático pero que sin
embargo fue producida y filmada
completamente en colombia está
protagonizada por la británica tilda
swinton que representa una mujer que
viene a visitar a su hermana al país
sudamericano y empieza a escuchar unos
ruidos extraños durante la alfombra roja
entonces los actores colombianos de la
película elkin díaz y juan pablo orrego
sacaron la bandera de colombia con las
siglas eso es en referencia a las
manifestaciones que han tenido lugar en
este país sudamericano en los últimos
meses sino también se presentó en
competición la francesa fons que hace
una crítica de la sociedad francesa a
través de una periodista de televisión y
la marroquí alto y fuerte que cuenta la
historia de un antiguo rapero
e intentan liberar a la juventud de las
tradiciones a través del hip hop sino
también empezaron a entregarse premios
aquí en el festival de cannes
concretamente de la cinefundación que
apoya a las escuelas de cine del mundo
el tercer lugar fue para la academia
internacional de cine de brasil
llegamos hacia el final de esta emisión
a ustedes gracias por su sintonía feliz
tarde para todos
[Música]